in the theater Clinic of this Beijing
Hospital the body of a patient is taken
away through a hallway filled with
people infected by covert 19. beds and
rooms are in short supply a sudden
lifting of virus restrictions last month
sparked a nationwide surge in cases
it's forced staff to transform this
Hospital Lobby into a makeshift Ward for
extra patience dozens mostly elderly are
being monitored by a few doctors and
nurses
medical staff are under immense pressure
many have fallen ill themselves
here they've been instructed not to
speak to Media
we don't give interviews
the government says China's covid-19
situation is under control and the worst
of the outbreak is over but here at one
of the biggest hospitals in Beijing the
wards are still overflowing with people
and many have had to wait hours to see a
doctor
long queues fill emergency rooms some
who were turned away last week like this
man are trying a second time
there are more than 100 people before me
what you can do just wait my father is
88 years old it's very challenging for
people his age to recover from this
virus I'm very glad he's still alive
others aren't so fortunate this
crematorium in beijing's East is undated
with families waiting for the remains of
their loved ones to be attended to
one man who didn't want to be filmed
told us a recent influx has led to
delays
officially China has one of the lowest
covid-19 death tolls in the world but
the backlog here and at hospitals
Nationwide tells a different story
Katrina you altazira Beijing